Kevin woody make a Dusty's explanation
as to why Strasbourg won't start in
tonight's elimination game
interesting Chris Rose always tells me
we're all not wired the same obviously
first thing you're like what
wheezing on the treadmill you're
thinking that this rain delay favored
the Nationals 100% rainout and now
you're thinking Strassburger and then go
deal however they want to go on the next
day in game 5 if they got by game 4
it doesn't make sense to me I don't know
the whole story
but we're all not wired the same I guess
Danny yeah I'm just trying to figure out
I know that maybe it it can help them if
they get to a game five but how do you
think this place in the clubhouse with
the Nationals you know if I was in the
clubhouse it wouldn't play great you
know that's how I could speak because I
know we went through a lot of stuff in
Boston or no three no four trying to
come down and shock the world and do all
this stuff and shave heads and then
you're thinking rainout Wow
Stephen Strasburg no-hit stuff our guy
he and Max Scherzer on a one-two punch
what make our team great other than our
offense but they make our team great and
then were maybe not feeling good I don't
know what that means Danny I really
don't think E's and Indians with Game
five coming up tonight is there a chance
that Terry Francona has mismanaged his
rotation no accident is for us to go
holy cow he nailed it because Bauer Game
one didn't make sense to all of us it
would have been like Dave Roberts saying
the richfield's going to start Game one
and Clayton Kershaw was going Game two
it didn't make sense but the reason why
they do it and when I say they it's not
just Terry Francona these days you've
got 19 guys coming down to the front
office with every number possible if it
goes to a game five we have Corey Kluber
are a are by Young award-winner at home
on his rest here we go and this is wait
it's kind of planned well that's what I
wondered if and when it originally came
out I thought okay he's
not only planning for the ales he's
planning for the ALCS like he wants to
get his rotation where he would have
Kluber going everything would be set up
it was just when they ended up losing
back-to-back games I thought maybe this
would come back and haunt them but you
feel good about Cleveland going into
this game tonight I do and you have to I
mean blankie didn't step up for the
Dodger situation against the Dodgers and
you're paying the guy 31 nine dollars so
that's their guy it didn't happen in
Arizona to keep their series going Corey
Kluber in Cleveland Game five place
should be rocket I think there's 38,000
there I want to say this is this is what
you live for like what else do you want
here we go guys this is he's shy young
and he's got a frisbee slider I know
game one or game two they got to them
early and Sanchez hit the home run
right-center but let me tell you
something this might be a different type
in for the for the Indians how surprised
were you the Dodgers handled the
Diamondback so easily surprised I looked
at that series Arizona coming in pretty
good pretty hot and obviously the
Dodgers we weren't really sure if
they're over their stuff they're little
of the little funk they went into but
I'm gonna tell you right now they look
like the team that was on pace to win
120 games they just do a whole bunch of
stuff good they just do a whole budget
they give you tough of bats
they're great out of bullpen and you
just sit around here like man they just
give you they just give you that it
factor whatever that being Kevin Millar
Major League Baseball Network analyst
joining us Dan Patrick show if I said
the Astros or the Dodgers better team
who would you pick Astros offense
dominating doesn't get enough doesn't
get enough credit let's get that
straight they come they score first they
score a lot they hit homers Altuve you
still don't understand it it doesn't
make sense it gives every kid hope in
the world to play in the show he's five
foot two and a half but I'm telling you
right now don't sleep on the Astros but
I would got at such a time by the way
ban real quick for answer it Kevin
Millar [ __ ] in March Dodgers
Astros World Series Astros win it in
2017 that was in March they're still
alive I go Astros so you just went
third-person pat on the back person
yeah well listen this is how we roll now
Kevin lessen Kevin so you have I don't
like me I don't like me so you still
like Dodgers Astros for the World Series
I really do okay you know what you know
why though real quick I just think that
sometimes natural disasters have
something and and meanings in cities and
we and we kind of go around it I mean
not saying that the Boston bombing in
2013 was a natural disaster but we know
it was devastating to this country and
that city and the Red Sox win the World
Series in 2013
hurricane Harvey was very angry and
they're still people devastated in that
city in Houston you never know how
sports work what could you get going
deep with your prediction I'm deep come
on yeah what do you do during a rainout
rain delay if you're a player there's a
lot of cards a lot of gambling going on
cribbage a lot of blu-ray mmm probably
now these days there's a lot of health
food shakes and protein and kale and
sandwich bar my BAE Snickers you had
tobacco stands so it's changed now when
you walk in a locker room it's it's
totally we are organic in the society I
mean look at the way you eat now and
look at the way you ate when you were
with ESPN yeah I mean you look great now
Dan yeah you've aged well thank you
Kevin thank you thank you you've always
had a good eye I'll give you credit for
that Kevin Dan would like to say that he
really appreciates you complimenting Dan
hey Dan love Dan don't don't sleep on
that statement right now we're gonna go
through a person with you where are you
gonna be tonight by the way what I'm
just telling you I got Trent Dilfer
walking up to the range right now it's
58 degrees he's in shorts and a hat play
ball and he calls baseball
dick ball but I'm gonna tell you right
now he's at a disadvantage I'm in pants
I'm in sleeves he's gonna be cold he's
got no hair either damn have fun all
right
play nice all right buddy I'll let you
know how it went all right thanks keV
all right boys thanks a lot Kevin laughs
Major League Baseball Network the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience